Encuentra el máximo factor común de los siguientes monomios ¿Ok? Y con monomios se refieren a
expresiones que tienen un solo término ¿Ok? Que son un bonche de cosas multiplicándose y estas 3 expresiones
claramente son, cada una de ellas, un solo término entonces, son monomios. Y lo que queremos es encontrar su máximo
factor común ¿Ok? Una expresión que divida a cada una de estas expresiones
y que además sea en cierto sentido, la expresión más grande que lo hace.
¿Ok? Y para hacer eso a mí lo que me gusta, es tomar cada uno de estos términos y
partirlo en la multiplicación de los factores más chicos que los componen ¿Ok? En el caso de estos números
eso es su factorización en primos.
Entonces, podemos empezar por ahí. Vamos a dividir a esta expresión en sus partes más elementales.
Esto de aquí es igual a, el 10 es tal cual 2 por 5 ¿Ok?
Esta es su factorización en números primos, no podríamos encontrar números más sencillos que multiplicados nos den 10,
después esto lo vamos a multiplicar por,
aquí a esta "c" no la podemos escribir en términos más simples,
entonces la vamos a dejar tal cual como una "c"
y eso está multiplicándose por
"d" al cuadrado y este "d" al cuadrado si lo podemos escribir como multiplicación de cosas más sencillas
las cuales son pues "d" por "d".
Bueno vamos con el siguiente, la factorización en primos de 5
es simplemente un 5 por que 5 ya es un primo,
por el "c", no lo podemos dividir más entonces lo dejamos tal cual, al "d"
tampoco lo podemos simplificar más
entonces lo dejamos como un "d", y el último término
escribimos la factorización en primos de 25 y eso es 5 por 5 y eso es
5 por 5, 25 y cada uno de estos es primo muy bien, luego "c" al cubo es la multiplicación de "c" por "c" por "c".
¿Cierto? Y "d" cuadrada es simplemente "d" por "d".
Entonces ya partimos cada uno de estos términos, de estos monomios en su descomposición en partes más
fundamentales, que pudimos encontrar, que en el caso de las variables es simplemente la variable
y en el caso de los números es su
factorización en primos, y ahora lo que queremos hacer es encontrar el máximo
factor común y para eso, lo que vamos a hacer es buscar en estas descomposiciones , en factores primos,
podríamos llamarles así,
¿Cuáles son los factores que tienen todos los términos? ¿Ok? Por ejemplo todos estos términos tienen a un 5
entonces, déjame lo círculo. Este término tiene un 5 por aquí,
este término tiene un 5 por acá,
y este término también tiene un 5, escojamos éste.
Entonces en esta factorización en factores primos, todos tienen un 5.
Así es que el 5 forma parte de nuestro máximo
factor común y además podemos ver que todos los términos también tienen una "c"
así es que vamos a circularlas "c", "c" y "c"
y ponerla en
nuestra factorización del máximo factor común,
y podemos observar que cada término tiene también una  "d" y "d" y "d"
y el asunto aquí es que estos 3 términos no tienen ningún otro factor
común por que aunque al primer término y al tercer término les quede todavía otra "d" en su factorización, al
segundo término ya no le queda nada.
Así es que el máximo factor común no tiene 2 "d" tiene nada más una y lo mismo pasa con ésta "c" cuadrada
así es que nuestro máximo factor común es
5 por "c" por "d" ¿Ok? Y no podía ser más grande que eso
porque uno de nuestros términos del cual estamos
encontrando el máximo factor común es 5cd y ningún factor común puede ser más grande que una de las
expresiones de las cuales estamos sacando el máximo factor común.